he actually blocked a kick with his hand
forearm don't do that at home folks hand
or forearm against shin like look at
this who wins
hi my name is miriam nakamoto i'm an
eight-time muay thai world champion and
i've been doing it for over two decades
today we're going to be looking at muay
thai scenes from movies and tv and we're
going to judge how real they are
her form is great on those elbows so
elbows is the
shortest range weapon of a muay thai
fight there's a up elbow
and then there is a round elbows
and then there's like a tomahawk elbow
and then there's spike elbows too
so what she's doing in this scene is a
spike elbow in a muay thai fight i would
not elbow anywhere but the head because
if you're elbowing somewhere else that
means your head is down where there's
like a lot of danger so that was very
very very realistic
that no that's not muay thai what muay
thai is is you take a boxing match and
then you add not only
punches but you add in kicks and not
only kicks you can also
elbow
knee and standing grappling
my kick is awesome i need to learn that
the spinning kick looked correct it's
not common
you wouldn't see that very often in a
muay thai fight
usually you just see round kick you see
the foot jabs you see the low kick a
question mark kick where it comes up
here and then it goes around well i'll
say 8 out of 10 just because that whole
uh jumping up on the shoulders thing and
flinging yourself down is like no that's
not going to happen but everything else
looked great
that tree
i think that's doable but in america
that is not common people do kick tires
not full blast but just kind of
repetitive stress or they'll kick really
heavy hard bags i would um kick really
hard tie pads or you could kick a banana
tree
[Music]
it's absolutely 100
realistic and vital to
condition your shins shin is your shield
you block kicks with your shins you
apply damage with your shins but he
keeps pointing his toes there he is
pointing his toes some more
we don't do the toe pointing thing
because as a muay thai kick you want to
cut cut them in half
as you point your toes you actually end
up kind of putting some force that way
instead of going this way it would kind
of take some of your energy
away from your target
people do
do a lot of pool conditioning now you
could work on your breath for sure you
could work on lung capacity i think that
would be valuable you need body
conditioning you want to be dense you
want to be durable
[Music]
if you go into muay thai gym and the
coach tries to string you up like that
get the hell out of there as quickly as
possible flexibility is important you
could like
just lay on your back with um your legs
open facing up in the wall or you can
have someone like push down when you do
a butterfly stretch they push down on
your thighs and you like try to close
them
um
i've never seen anybody throw coconuts
at someone to train their core but i
have seen
you get hit people with medicine balls
you kind of take the medicine ball and
you're like
as you do your sit-ups and your crunches
or they put a glove on and they'll punch
you oftentimes too you'll like stand
with your hands behind your back and
then they'll just like kick i'll give it
a four it's important to stretch yes
it's important to
develop lung capacity it's important to
have a strong core but the way they're
going about it is totally not anything
that i've seen done
ever
[Music]
his teep is beautiful the teep is
it's a foot jab you can see it starts
from his back leg
comes up his body and goes pat right out
through the lead leg that would be the
position you'd be in in a muay thai
fight but yeah a tip is good if somebody
keeps coming in on you and you want to
get space
a high kick to the head looks cool and
if you have a nice head kick it's a
great knockout but for me i prefer to
kick to the body with the head kick if
you hit the top of your foot to
somebody's skull yes it hurts them but
yes it hurts you too and i'm not trying
to be limping around you know with a
messed up foot for a month after that
fight
for muay thai
i've never seen that stance because he
was really really low to the ground
it's never that low i guess that's uh
boron and so they do more of that and
i'm just more straight up the logic and
muay thai of standing taller is as
you're getting kicked and as you want
access to your kicks the lower you are
the longer it's going to take to get
your leg up there but if you're already
standing taller you can just rotate your
body and it's there
if you can catch their chin
yes it's a short night i've had a lot of
knee surgeries probably not in my in the
cards for me unfortunately but what i
find is awesome about knees is
when you're lighting somebody up with
knees to the body it actually takes the
fight out of them kind of tenderizes the
meat and his his form is perfect in his
knees by rotating the femur in then your
lower half of your leg and your foot
goes kind of outward then you point your
toes and it creates a much more lancing
effect and you can also get more range
on your knee too which keeps you further
away from danger as you're
implementing damage
[Applause]
so those punches were terrible but it's
a stunt scene i did one stunt scene and
i was like oh this is not even real at
all for a film you'd want to take it out
and around so you can really like see it
and sell it
but when you're actually fighting you
want to just keep it tight to your body
you don't want to lift your elbow just
want to rotate just disguise it because
the more you have a tell
the more your opponent sees it and they
can prepare for that
that is accurate the knee shield keeping
somebody
off you that's definitely a legitimate
thing to get space
i firmly believe he can jump up there
and put his both his knees like that but
yeah that's not happening in a fight
that's too much of a gamble i mean
you're spending a lot of time in air you
could stay on the ground and just like
drive forward and like slam an elbow
into their face
and they bow yeah that's accurate too i
was about an opponent whether you win or
you lose i said i have to rate it high
because it's 20 jaw
i would say 9 out of 10.
you mean you're going to fight me using
weight tie
not only am i going to use it i'm going
to rearrange your face with it a bunkle
is uh something that they you wear your
teacher gives it to you you do not fight
with it on for spiritual reasons and
then you
can't go under the ropes wearing it it's
disrespectful you gotta go over the
ropes when you fight you take it off
that's it the invincible tiger knee blow
that made him famous i've never in my
life come across
a tiger knee it's a knee buddy this is
just plain only it is absolutely
effective to knee somebody in the
stomach it is absolutely effective to
add momentum with the flying knee and
it's not as risky because it's um your
feet are still underneath you it's just
forward momentum
i can see muay thai has many levels to
be mastered
the first person who looked like they
did more damage
got whooped by the second person who
looked like they did less and then he
talks about like there's different
levels to muay thai to master i don't
know what he's talking about it is not
you know kill bill when they did that
secret punch to the heart it's a boom
boom boom and punches him and then you
know kills bill no there's nothing like
that in muay thai that i am aware of
after 23 years i'll give him a two
because of the monk hole no actually i
have to take that away because he's
fighting with it on so zero out of ten
yes foot stomp heck yeah definitely do
those knees the kick not as much
i don't know why you would be kicking in
that really small space there's a lot
better things you could use i would do
punches
elbows and knees because those are the
more close range weapons and then the
push kick would be good too because
they're in front of you you wouldn't
really do round kicks and high kicks
because you have to like go out and
around like yeah no you want to you want
it to just go this way he actually
blocked a kick with his like his hand
forearm don't do that at home folks hand
or forearm against shin
like look at this who wins
you can get your arm broken get your
hand broken
well i like that he he keeps trying to
cover and block that would be
definitely what you want to do i mean
the hands are kind of all over the place
yeah you don't want to be
that's not good if somebody's
striking at you you just need your hands
up
i would give it a six because it's
basically if you have a hallway in your
house you're gonna have like full blown
fight
so what they're doing is they're doing
the y crew or ramoy and they have the
monkols on
and it's a spiritual dance they're
definitely doing that correctly but so
it's hard to say every school has a
different
dance specific to their school
this clinch part is correct this is the
grappling portion of a muay thai fight
so you seek to control position with
your hands
and your arms and your head he has him
like this he's controlling the arm
the other arm's over here and his hand
is over here on the side of that guy's
neck
you find control by either bringing them
closer to you and deliver strikes at the
same time or by creating space and get
making a frame with experienced pros
like they're not going to you know do
all this it's going to be more
controlled
don't do that
you're gonna eat a nice hard piece of
bone
and that's not gonna feel good he was
standing in front of a tie fighter in a
tie fight with their hands up and he was
in front of the tie fighter like
punching with his hands down you would
never do that that's elbow range you
need to have your hands up
oh and then he swept him that was
correct there's a bunch of different
ways you can sweep them he grabbed the
leg
lifted the leg and
turned him you can also sweep your
opponent by either
body locking
and getting an angle and dumping or as
they knee you sweep their leg you can
take them back over your thigh
if you get an angle on them
i gave it eight out of ten that's pretty
good
yeah this is totally not realistic
i'm just here for that outfit
the performer is doing elbows and
they're elbowing like this
the thing with elbows is if you're in
elbow range and you're elbowing they
have elbows too so you never want to
throw an elbow
with the other hand down
because that's
you'll be cut open
that kick was really silly he's just
spinning around lifting the leg up but
it's like even with a punch it's not
just about this this kicking is not just
lifting the leg it starts with your foot
connection to the ground and the
rotation of your foot and it's like your
your foot your ankle your knee then your
hip and then the last bit is this and so
the same thing with a muay thai kick if
you want to kick with the right side it
starts with the left side of your body
actually you want to rotate the opposite
side of your body
to um sling the kick and then the leg
comes after i know that it's stunts and
you have to kind of cheat it
but you still can like make it
so it looks right instead of kind of
flailing
two out of ten
that was like all completely off my
favorite
of the clips viewed today was
raya the last dragon their body
mechanics made a lot of sense the fight
scene made sense that was cool there was
two women too
you know that was really neat thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video why
not click the video above